keanu he does kung-fu or not coming
through he knows karate kung-fu Chinese
47 Ronin is not 47 kyani so 47 Ronin
takes place in field of Japan you know
old-school samurai Japan which means it
has that guy who plays a badass samurai
and everything swear to God that guy
could be in a sequel to Slingblade
gravity comes on scene I'll be like oh
there's a samurai and Slingblade - holy
[ __ ] that's just weird but I know he's
at Lee's gonna be awesome and they treat
Keanu Reeves like some second-class
citizen they're like eh you're a piece
of [ __ ] no one likes you but then a big
cliche batty takes over the land I think
he honorees and the 47 Ronin have to
take him down I guess it would be keanu
in the 46 so says the man so we got
America's favorite bad actor in a movie
with 47 Ronin taking back the kingdom
how was it holy [ __ ] what a snooze my
god how can you screw that up I just
wanted a cool action movie to be honest
I thought it was gonna be like 300 in
Japan so 47 nothing was happening in
this movie I check my watch I was like
all right well 45 minutes in then
nothing was happening still except for
couple cool things to be fair a couple
cool things did happen check my watch
again I was like it's been another 45
minutes dozen hour and a half but in the
last half hour the movie things start
happening and it looks really cool in
the movie ends when I look at it I feel
like the first 45 minutes of this movie
could have been summed up in some
prologue the Lord of the Rings hava
style was like these people mind a big
drink came out of nowhere it took the
land paraphrase it as you want there it
is there's the history now we're into
our movie but they didn't I was bored
shitless funny thing is Keanu Reeves is
not the problems you're a lot of people
will get on yours like it's Keanu Reeves
a good kid it'd be Keanu Reeves is like
one of the cool parts of the movie there
are a couple of cool scenes just one
scene in particular at the end of the
first 45 minutes slow as [ __ ] part where
I was like that was a cool death I like
that st. another was gonna set a tone
and turn this whole movie on its head
and be like all right now it's a really
good movie I feel like no one's gonna
walk away from this movie satisfied if
you like cool action in movies you're
gonna walk away from this movie be like
this is boring as hell but if you're
like boring movies that means you
probably like movies that are Oscar
contenders this is not an Oscar
contender however if you like boring as
[ __ ] movies that will not get nominated
for Oscars that have no character
development whatsoever hey guess what I
found four
you 47 Ronin we've got your back this
guy I feel bad for Japan as in the
country itself at the beginning of this
movie they'd like to know the story is
to know Japan I was like all right so
this is like Japanese John Adams this is
what you guys get I'm really sorry I
just walked out gun I hope they get a
mulligan at this whole story because
that that wasn't good enough this movie
did have a couple of cool parts they had
a couple of good characters the best
part were the two main characters they
had the most character in the movie you
wanted to see them avenge people those
two guys single-handedly brought this
movie up to be good enough for me to say
47 Ronin Saul right but you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus 10 minutes yeah
already forgot I liked the mythology of
the movie and like I said a couple of
cool things do happen in a couple of
parts where you're like that sighs all
right the movie stepping up yeah I guess
not another 45 minutes of a sloppy ass
mess there's a 47 Ronin have you seen it
what did you think about it or if you
want to be a little more creative what
is the movie where Keanu Reeves did his
best acting job not the matrix don't you
can't don't cheat whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more